Okay, for the viewers watching,
this is my fifth voice over,
just so you all know. Anyways,
we're gonna put some good skin prep on, okay?
We're gonna get all the skin prepped and ready to go
for a nice makeup look. We're gonna conceal these bags.
It's crucial to conceal them.
Now we're blending this off,
blending it in together. We're gonna flick up the eyebrows,
make them look so slick, like a cow licked it.
Now we're gonna highlight on the cheekbones,
on the nose. Blend, blend,
blend, blend, blend, mix,
mix, mix.
Now for the hero, it's the blush.
Now listen, people don't do a lot of blush,
cause then you just look like a clown. Okay?
Just a nice little layer, a nice little kiss.
Now we're gonna blend more.
I think it was highlighting.
Yeah, we're blending more.
Putting stuff on her eyes,
setting that stuff with a good setting spray,
adding some eyelashes in. This is looking good.
Now touch, touch, touch,
light, light, light, finish,
finish, finish.
Now the lips, okay?
The lips, the lips,
the lips. It's all about the lips.
We got a little combo here to give us this look.